quattro anni fa l'oxford
scenari hai letto parola dell'anno post
truth post verità confesso che quando ho
sentito questa notizia ho sorriso
sorriso con la saccenza di chi è del
mestiere e che pensa che capiti solo
agli altri di interpretare le notizie
attraverso la del sentimento filtrandole
insomma attraverso i sentimenti è però
oggi a distanza di quattro anni mi devo
ricredere
mi devo ricredere perché è capitato
anche a me e mi è capitato durante la
quarantena in quel periodo le notizie
erano tantissime e io non avevo
nient'altro da fare che ascoltare le
notizie che ricevevo sul compito 19 un
giorno leggo la notizia data dal
ministro della sanità francese che mette
in guardia sull'assunzione di ibuprofene
in relazione al co lead 19 a quanto lui
dice questo farmaco potrebbe peggiorare
i sintomi della malattia e addirittura
farla diventare letale
ovviamente ciò che dice è anche
supportato da una ricerca scientifica
che è stata pubblicata in una rivista
autorevoli sì ma la rivista medica the
lancet subito panico ho pensato ma io
sto assumendo ibuprofene e poi subito
dopo
markovic eh sì ma se mi prendo il covip
o se lo sto già incubando e poi ho detto
calma cristina rifletti confronta ciò
che hai letto con ciò che sai ciò che so
è che come i tempi non ci siamo proprio
sapevamo di questo virus solo da un paio
di mesi non sapevamo ancora come curarlo
non c'erano farmaci come poteva esserci
già una ricerca proprio sugli effetti
collaterali dei farmaci
ciò che so è anche che uno studio
clinico si sviluppa attraverso una fase
che dura molti anni e poi so anche che
uno studio clinico una volta che è stato
completato deve essere verificato i
risultati vengono verificati da chi ne
ha i mezzi e la competenza
questo processo si chiama processo di
revisione paritaria ed è un processo che
coinvolge tutti i campi della ricerca
scientifica non solo la ricerca clinica
solo dopo la revisione paritaria un
articolo può essere pubblicato
e comunque anche i tempi editoriali di
pubblicazione non sono brevi per cui
come poteva esserci già uno studio dopo
pochi mesi cerco su google qualche
notizia inserendo le parole chiave
comito 19 e ibuprofene e la prima
notizia che appare è questa
capisco subito che non è così affidabile
lo capisco dal titolo perché il titolo
riporta due notizie entrambe vere
la notizia di un giovane uomo che è
morto a causa del covip e la notizia che
questo stesso uomo assumeva ibuprofene
due notizie vere però messe insieme così
nel titolo suggeriscono una correlazione
con relazione che è tutta da dimostrare
e quindi secondo me questo titolo è più
un illazione che una notizia
vado a vedermi che ha scritto l'articolo
vado a vedere se posso fidarmi del
giornalista che l'ha scritto
ma anche qui la sorpresa l'articolo è
firmato
genericamente la redazione quindi un
articolo anonimo tutto sommato lo prendo
e lo cestino ma prima però do
un'occhiata per capire se l'articolo
cita anche quella ricerca pubblicata da
lancet
anzi ancora meglio se in quell'articolo
c'è il link che mi porta direttamente
alla pagina dell'ain set
ovviamente non c'è nulla allora altra
ricerca su google e vado a cercare
questa volta direttamente la
pubblicazione scientifica
l'articolo lo trovo praticamente subito
ma non si tratta di uno studio clinico
in revisione paritaria si tratta di un
articolo che esplora il problema
suggerendolo suggerendo di indagare
ulteriormente la strada della
correlazione farmaco malattia quindi è
solo un suggerimento di indagine non uno
studio clinico
ecco che un'informazione con una base di
verità passando di bocca in bocca si è
trasformata in leggenda
però se abbiamo o molto spesso ragione
di dubitare di ciò che leggiamo
difficilmente noi dubitiamo di ciò che
vediamo
sì perché siamo abituati a credere a ciò
che vediamo con i nostri occhi
e infatti poco tempo dopo mi è successo
anche questo
mi scrive una dottoranda indiana ci ho
conosciuto durante uno dei miei corsi e
mi scrive con grande preoccupazione le
notizie che le giungono dall'italia sono
veramente terribili e lei è preoccupata
per me vuole sapere come sto
in questa mail mi dice anche che l'ha
emozionata tantissimo vedere questa foto
che è stata condivisa su facebook dove
ci sono tutte queste bare allineate
centinaia centinaia di bare allineate in
attesa di sepoltura
anch'io provo momento di emozione no
nell'evocare questa immagine per poi
qualcosa mi scatta in testa e ragiono e
dico ma sepoltura ma le vittime del
copit vengono cremate allora le chiedo
di mandarmi l'immagine e lei mi manda
questa foto non ho assolutamente motivo
di dubitare della foto mi sembra una
foto vera non è modificata e come può
essere carico la foto su google immagini
per vedere se è stata pubblicata anche
in altri siti oltre che a facebook per
vedere se ci sono altre fonti che
richiamano questa immagine e la trovo
quasi subito perché un'immagine anche
famosa un'immagine d'archivio
un'immagine che si è stata scattata in
italia è una foto che è stata scattata
in italia ma non delle vittime del copit
in quelle bare ci sono le salme delle
vittime di un naufragio al largo della
costa di lampedusa
ecco che un'immagine reale nel momento
in cui è stata decontestualizzata ha
creato una leggenda
se non possiamo fidarci di ciò che
leggiamo se non possiamo fidarci di ciò
che vediamo è sicuramente dei numeri ci
fidiamo i numeri non mentono i numeri
sono dati così quando ho sentito per la
prima volta alla tv
una notizia che oggi ormai è quasi
quotidiana e cioè che i casi di coop ed
19 sono in continuo aumento
ma questo è parzialmente giustificato
dal fatto che anche il numero dei
tamponi è in continuo aumento
non ho avuto assolutamente motivo di
dubitare di questo dato e mi sono anche
inizialmente sentita tranquilla no però
ancora una volta ho deciso di
confrontare ciò che so
con ciò che sento ciò che so è che i
numeri è vero non mentono
ma i numeri possono essere analizzati
interpretati contestualizzati fino ad
assumere significati diversi di volta in
volta ciò che so è che possiamo leggere
i dati in tanti modi diversi
ecco che quella all'abile tranquillità
che la notizia mi aveva trasmesso così
di primo acchito mi abbandona subito sì
perché io con i dati ci lavoro e so che
potrò sentirmi veramente tranquillo solo
quando il numero dei tamponi aumenterà i
casi
diminuiranno anche i numeri possono
diventare leggende nell'era della posta
verità nessuno nessuno di noi è
veramente immune dalle notizie false o
inesatte se lasciamo che le emozioni
predominino sulla ragione rischiamo di
non saper più distinguere ciò che è
affidabile da ciò che non lo è per
questo oggi più che mai è importante
fermarsi riflettere confrontare ciò che
sentiamo che leggiamo che vediamo con
ciò che conosciamo
le nostre conoscenze sono la nostra
memoria immunitaria la nostra capacità
di ragionare e l'unico vero vaccino
contro la disinformazione